Yo, what's up? What's your background?
>> Why does your name I play guitar? Sound
familiar? But go ahead.
>> Uh, I've been watching for about a year.
I was baptized last year. I'm Catholic.
>> Um, my question is, well, I was I was
looking at your blog just yesterday or
day before and I I saw your latest
article. Um, a Bible error.
>> On who?
>> Bible area.
>> Yeah. Um, I wasn't aware that there was
actually any like anything like that in
the Bible. And so I was wondering what
>> there are that they point to.
>> What does it mean for like infallibility
and uh inherency?
>> I don't know what you mean. Infallible.
What does inherency mean?
>> Yeah. So like if we say the Bible is
infallible and inherent. I mean
>> infallible meaning that it's it's
completely reliable in what it says.
Right.
>> Right.
>> Okay.
>> And inherent meaning like no errors. Um,
>> and even what do you mean by no errors?
>> Yeah, that's what I don't know. Is it is
it the original scripture that was
written that would
>> the belief is the belief is that when
God inspired the authors, he would
superintend their writing in such a way
they won't make any factual mistakes,
but it doesn't mean that extends the
copious because what did I say earlier
to someone? If you want perfect copies
that have no variations, forget about
just alleged discrepancies between two
accounts that seem contradictory, just
to make sure copists don't make mistakes
in copying. that involves God working in
a miraculous fashion that whenever a
scribe, any scribe wants to copy the
Bible, the spirit will somehow come upon
that person that all the scribes will
then be inspired in such a way that they
will not make mistakes in copying
because prior to the printing press,
anything that's written by hand, you
like it or not, you're going to make
mistakes. Even today with Microsoft
Word, how many times we misspell
something and then we see the word in
red signifying to us this is an error.
Correct it.
Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So if we do that today with this
sophisticated technology, people without
this technology writing by hand with an
ink and in poor lighting or in poor
conditions, you expect they're not going
to make mistakes?
>> Yeah. No. In fact, even when when you're
going growing up in school, when you had
to write down something on a chalkboard,
I don't know if you're that young, but
were when you went to school, did you
did they write things on a chalkboard?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Then you remember and then you had
to write it down and the class did.
Could you point to anyone next to you
who then wrote down what he saw in the
exact same way you did?
>> No.
>> Why?
>> Um because we're not perfect.
Unless God does a work on all of you,
then you're not going to have flawless
copies from a group of students of what
they see on the board. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> That's the same thing with copying any
book
prior to the printing press. In fact,
they have what they call scriptorums
where a person would dictate the copy he
had and the people sitting there would
have to write down what they hear. Now,
can you imagine the variations that
would take place when they're doing
that?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So then what the belief of inherency is
that the original wording of the
original author is preserved in the
manuscripts. It's not lost. But then we
have sufficient copies to know what the
original wording is in about
97 98% of the time. And even that
difference, that 2% difference, that has
to do with the fact of not being
absolutely certain which of the two
variants or three is the original, but
it's still there. You want me there?
Nothing lost.
>> Yeah, thanks for clearing that up for
me.
>> Let me and let me give you the example
of the one you pointed even here. If you
notice, this is one the Muslims love. I
guys, I posted this yesterday from Gleon
Archer.
2 Chronicles 22:2 state that Heziah was
42 when he began to reign. But 2 Kings
8:26 says he was 22. Now the reason why
you have a discrepancy is because Hebrew
doesn't have numbers. Letters stand for
numbers. You know that, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Hebrew there were no numbers 1, two, and
three. The letters represent numbers.
Like alf would mean one, right?
So the reason why we have a discrepancy
in the Hebrew manuscripts is because at
some stage in transmission someone may
have misread a letter
instead of reading it 22 he saw the
letter and he thought it meant 42.
Right?
>> Yep.
>> Now how do we know what the original
reading is? Well, we know Isaiah would
not have reigned at 42. He would be much
younger. But secondly, because when we
have ancient versions
of the Old Testament written in various
languages, we then find that in the
Greek
versions of 2 Chronicles and Syriak, it
reads 22.
Some septit manuscripts, the Greek and
Syriak read 22.
So now we know what the original is. But
even if we were not, which we could tell
it's 22 because 42 he'd be too old. That
means he'd be reigning with his father
as a vice regent.
Even if it's 42
and here it's 22. Even let's say we
don't know how to resolve the tension.
How does this impact the very message
and doctrine of the Christian church?
>> Yeah, it doesn't. Exactly.
>> Yeah. Like you've still got the fact
that Christ raised from uh was raised
from the dead. Like you Yeah.
>> The only Yeah. The only thing we'd have
is that scribes poorly copied the
original or had a defective copy and
that scribe poorly copied the one before
him. So all you're saying is well now
yeah somehow in the transmission a
copist made a mistake and the guy who
came after him saw 42 when it should
have been 22. But that also argues for
[snorts] the fidelity, the faithfulness
of the scribes. What do I mean?
The scribes saw, because the Jews
obviously read their Old Testament, they
commented, they saw the discrepancy, and
yet they still kept 42 in some of their
manuscripts.
Why didn't they just change it? because
out of fear of God, they didn't want to
change the 42 cuz they may have assumed.
Well, this probably is the original
number and I'm just going to keep it
nonetheless and find a way of
harmonizing it.
>> So, even the discrepancy that is still
there testifies that for the most part
the scribes would not alter the text
unless they were fully convinced that
they're reading a mistake made by the
scribe before them.
they would keep it in
>> unless they were convinced no that can't
be right. the because remember the
scribe is copying a copy and he knows
the scribe before him ain't going to be
perfect unless he had absolutely good
reason to think no man that sky must
have been asleep or maybe it was poor
lighting or poor eyesight that can't be
right I'm going to rectify it which some
tribes did like oops well hey it says 42
and I'm sticking with 42
>> you see
>> yeah thank you because I was also weird
that there was um an alternative
explanation to do with the the age of
the dynasty, but I wasn't sure whether
or not to bother with it and um because
you know obviously you would be aware of
other instances where you have to um
>> reach for explanation. Yeah. So,
>> well, here if you do this, I uploaded a
a series of posts that Jay Smith and
team did, but it's defunct. It's on his
website, and I found it's 101 cleared up
contradictions in the Bible, supposedly
101 discrepancy. So, there it is. You
just put 101 contradictions comes up. I
broke it down in four installments. Let
me get you the link to the first one.
Yeah. But the point is, I don't address
Bible discrepancies unless someone is
really asking from a sincere heart. Why?
Because when often times, and I'm
sending it to you in the private chat,
when oftentimes people ask me about
Bible discrepancies, they're not asking
to see if it can be harmonized. Because
if something can be harmonized and
there's no true contradiction, right?
>> Yeah.
>> If I can give you a plausible
harmonization, that means it can't be
truly a contradiction because a real
contradiction means you cannot harmonize
it. But we have to be careful. Let me go
a step further. My harmonization doesn't
mean it's the solution. Unless I have
the authors in front of me to ask them,
any harmonization
is simply an attempt to show there is no
real contradiction. Because a real
contradiction means it cannot be
harmonized. But if I can harmonize them,
that means there is no real
contradiction. But it doesn't mean my
harmonization is the answer. Because
unless I have the scribes in front of
me, I don't know how they would answer.
You get my point, right? Yeah.
>> So when I give you an harmonization, I
want everyone listen. I'm giving you
stuff that you may not even learn in
seminary. I'm not boasting. If I give
you an harmonization,
right? A harmonization.
The point is to show if they can be
harmonized, then there are no real
contradiction because a real
contradiction means you can't harmonize
them,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> But if I can harmonize them, that means
it's not a real contradiction. But my
harmonization is not inspired. It's not
revelation I got from God telling me
that's how you harmonize. So even the
harmonization
though it will show they can be
harmonized and reconciled that doesn't
mean that's the answer because unless
you have the writers in front of you,
you don't know how they would explain
the discrepancies.
>> Yeah. So keep that in mind when you're
looking at harmonizations. They're all
attempts and you may have five different
harmonizations of the same discrepancy.
But that just tells you if I can come up
with five ways to resolve the
contradiction because what is a
contradiction? Something that cannot be
reconciled,
>> right?
>> Yeah. So you're just proving you can
>> say it again. I'm sorry. Go ahead,
brother.
>> You're just demonstrating that you can
reconcile it, but you don't know exactly
how.
>> Yeah. Cuz let let me say I give you five
proposed harmonizations. All of them
resolve the tension showing there are no
contradiction. But which of the five is
the answer?
>> Yeah. You don't know.
>> All you need to arrest that is hm if it
can be reconciled there's no real
contradiction next. But why I don't
engage people on alleged Bible
discrepancies? Because most people they
don't want an answer because when you
give an answer they'll nitpick or then
they'll throw another 10 at you.
>> Yeah.
So that means they're not asking because
they want to know. See, you ask because
you want to know. But when someone asks
and I answer, then he brings me another
two. That means this guy doesn't care.
He just wants to destroy faith in the
Bible. So then I send him to whatever
religion and whatever god he believes.
And if it's a Muslim, I send him to the
black stone to kiss it.
>> Yeah.
>> You get it?
>> Yeah. Thank you.
>> That help you? Any other questions or
you good?
>> That's all. Thanks, Sam.
wrong. Pray for me and you that we
finish the race by the blood of Christ.
>> Thank you.
>> God bless you, brother.